i'm just gonna say this prey might be
one of the better predator films we have
seen in years and it's unfortunate it is
not gonna be seen in cinemas
[Music]
what's up guys it's me bobby talking
about prey here launching on disney plus
and hulu august 5th 2022 and i got to
tell you i liked this movie a lot more
than i thought i was going to like it i
watched the trailer i was a little bit
lukewarm on the trailer going
okay it's a prequel to get it you know
it's set with in the 1700s it's the
comanches versus the predator how the
hell are they going to beat this alien
warrior species that's got you know all
this modern weaponry how are they going
to do it
and then i thought of the original film
in 1987 and i remembered that nobody
could beat the predator with all the
machine guns all the body oil all the 25
inch biceps that we saw from call
weathers jesse ventura and arnold
schwarzenegger no
it took arnold getting all covered up in
mud
so the predator couldn't detect his heat
and then
he used sticks and ropes and rocks
you use his primal abilities to beat the
predator if you think about the movie in
that context this movie makes a lot of
sense but then you're probably thinking
oh okay yeah yeah yeah but now this
movie's got that now it's all about the
the female lead being the hero all the
guys are no good right
wrong
did you watch aliens did you watch
terminator terminator 2.
sigourney weaver linda hamilton
respectively did you watch those films
did you think that back then
because if you didn't you're not going
to think it on this one amber mid
thunder
her character is essentially a sigourney
weaver linda hamilton tied into one but
set in the 1700s with this comanche
tribe that is the movie if you're
thinking the guys are weak in this and
the women is all strong you're wrong in
that again without the men
in this comanche tribe she doesn't take
on the predator by any stretch of the
imagination this is a team effort this
is a film that will surprise you in that
regards if you're thinking this is gonna
be some quote-unquote woke film it isn't
it isn't guys throw that thought out of
the way dan trachtenberg did a great job
balancing this out he gave you context
of who this character was from the very
beginning why she is doing what she's
doing and you get this sense that it's
not a rey uh for or mary sue kind of
character from star wars force awakens
last jedi the last skywalker none of
that stuff no
you're getting that this character has
something to prove because her father
passed away giving a little bit of
insight to the character right now and
her brother is a great warrior and she
wants to be a hunter and a warrior as
well and so she's striving to do these
things even when she's not supposed to
do it this is not part of their culture
in the comanche tribe the women are the
you know they they take care of the home
and cook and things like that she's
doing something out of the norm and
and there's a reason for it there's a
drive there that she wants to prove to
herself okay i respect that i like that
and the fact that she is not perfect and
she makes mistakes along the way but she
does use her brain
makes it interesting and it makes it a
different dichotomy than what we've been
used to seeing out there from a lot of
these films that just try to push out
agendas we're not getting that in this
film i'm just putting that out there so
you guys can just cool your horses on
that because you know a lot of people
may not address it but i'm going to
address the tree straight on it ain't
that kind of film okay great um getting
back to the premise of it we've already
seen the trailers which is pretty much
the movie uh it's unfortunate the
trailers are like a tick-tock cut of the
movie and i wish disney or 20th century
fox would have added a little bit more
suspense so we kind of
we kind of go into this movie not
knowing exactly how it's gonna
uh play out but you kind of do when you
watch it but nonetheless it is still fun
to watch there's some glorious kills in
this film by the predator he's not the
predator that we've seen previously this
is more of a primitive predator with
different weaponry not as it advanced so
that does make it a little bit um
easier to digest when you're watching
him fight the comanches and vice versa
because you understand okay that there
are some limitations with this predator
and
this predator is a little bit different
i would say we don't go much into the
exploratory aspect of this predator as
much as i would have liked to have seen
because you know in all the predator
films we kind of know if you watch the
series or the franchise you know that
they are on earth to hunt they're
collecting trophies
but if you never watch any of the other
movies and you're watching this is your
first predator film you would have no
idea which is a little bit unfortunate i
think that's a misstep in this film they
could have given a little bit of
backstory i mean look in every batman
movie you always get some sort of scene
where bruce wayne is with his parents
and they get shot even if they just show
it as a flashback you get the premise so
you understand why he's the way he is
but you don't get that with the predator
and i feel like hopefully they will do a
little bit more of that in the future if
they continue on with this franchise so
at least we get something i mean it's
nice to see right at least something
refreshing but nonetheless this predator
does have some
he's still trying to figure out what
this planet's about he's trying to
figure out who's the aggressor who's not
and there are some aspects to where if
you don't attack or you're not
aggressive you're not don't hold
anything a threat to him
he doesn't attack you but if you do well
good luck you know
you might have not have a head anymore a
leg or an arm or intestines but yeah
there's some glorious kills in this
folks you're gonna love that but
nonetheless this film does go on an
interesting journey and
what i like about it is
that you do see aspects of the comanche
in this that is not a two-dimensional
aspect you see more of a deeper dive
into their culture so they're much more
of a three-dimensional multi-dimensional
uh native american tribe so they're not
just the warriors the bad guys that we'd
always see portrayed in the american
westerns but there is other elements to
them there is you see that again that
respect for the land animals nature you
see that and then also you see the
french poachers that are coming to this
that are against all of that they're out
there for hides for money you see that
dichotomy happening coming into play but
also the predator is mixing this as well
and
it's interesting that there's a lot of
different layers into this film that
they kind of tie into it of course it's
in it's in a shorter run time uh you
know i mean if you really want to get
more exploratory in this you could make
this quite a long film if you really
want to get into that but you know dan
trachtenberg does keep it at a very fast
pace for the most part i think the first
part of the film does drag a little bit
till we get to the predator coming into
play then it starts getting to be a
little bit more exciting until then it's
a little bit like setting the stage but
i almost dozed off a couple times
watching this at home because we had to
watch it on our ipad because you know
advanced screening with massive
massive watermark on the front of it
that's another story for another day so
when you watch this film
you're going to get
elements that when you see that you know
if you go back and watch the previous
films you're gonna go ah
i get there's a there's a
consistency that goes along with this
and if you go back to billy from the 87
film native american this as well you
get a sense of that that pride that that
heroism that he had when he faced off
with a predator what everybody talked
about back then
you see that element here in this film
kind of but it's more into a deeper dive
and i like that it kind of ties a little
bit it's not part of the same tribe or
anything else like that no but it's
interesting how this sort of correlates
in some way shape or form interesting
but nonetheless i really like this film
um nothing to really spoil for you guys
because you've already pretty much seen
it everything which you see in the
trailer but
uh it's refreshing i like it and
um i don't know if they'll do a sequel
to this or not
i mean we kind of know how it ends
already right
ends the same way for every predator
movie but it is an interesting film and
i would say give it a shot watch it you
will be very surprised anyway those are
my thoughts on pray let me know your
thoughts in the comment section below
with that what you got more of our
videos right here we'll chat to you soon